the jurogan experience we should
probably tell people what happened
if people who don't know don't pay
attention you and bert were doing this
dunk challenge we so we were shooting
content
for our live show which was a new year's
eve live so that was like
exciting we had done one before where um
we played tennis
and we you know we had like just goofy
[ __ ] there's [ __ ] around
and we shot some sketches and stuff so
we
we have this idea we're like we competed
let's compete
let's do basketball and then we'll do a
dunk contest
we'll lower the rim and raise it and see
who can dunk on the highest
rim and that'll be part of the
competition you know
oh how dare you actually dunking this
was the video you just
know what they were doing before that's
that day yeah that's that how high is
that one
that one's like eight right and then
what's regulation ten can you dunk it
ten
no i dunked at nine though that's why i
beat bert
so this is like eight and a half right
there
and then the nine this is nine right
here
right so i beat him he couldn't do it
and it was over that's over right there
and then you did so right there they're
all like oh
and bert's like holy [ __ ] cause he
couldn't do it and i'm like oh it's over
and there's tristan jass we went with
he's like a really talented kid
basketball i won one excuse me i won
and uh and then right after this
one of those guys goes uh i think you
got you can go a little higher
and i was like i remember i felt the
adrenaline you know when someone's like
you got this and you're like
you feel like your throat kind of
tightened up yeah you know and that was
they raised it three inches
that's it from from that nine three so
you know just because i
i i didn't have a lot more room i was
like oh that was like it was clean
but i was like i can't i can't go that
much higher and just on the push off
push off on the left foot my left
patellar tendon snapped
now did you strain it before that not
that i
knew of i mean eventually when i talked
to the
doctor about it he was like this
probably would have happened
like doing something else what yeah why
he's just like you know he said it was
such a
strange place for the terror to take
place he's like it took
he first he goes he goes you know it
took a tremendous amount of force
to to do what you did how did you do
this i was like [ __ ] dunk contest
and he was like what i was like dunk
contest
he was like a slam dunk contest and i
was like yeah dude he was like okay
he goes well normally these patellar
tendons snap in like
one or two places and like you're
snapped in a place that it rarely
happens in
like it's not at one of the attachment
points it was like a quarter of the way
down
it's like it's very strange the way it
snapped hmm so
didn't you do like deadlifts or
something the day before that i did
squats
three days before were you sore when you
went to the dunking thing no we did i
was doing 255
uh sets of 12. okay so not really heavy
weight not crazy weight and like
i mean but not super light but like you
know being able to
i didn't have a problem with it and then
you know what i do remember this that
someone reminded me of this afterwards
at my office
that i do remember they were betting
whether i could do
nine feet at the office some people were
like yes no and i jumped in my
office in like jeans and a t-shirt and
touched the ceiling there
and i was like that felt funny oh
something felt funny in your knee yeah
here's the thing about tendons and
ligaments
especially ligaments when they snap they
don't hurt
i didn't hurt at all yeah it didn't hurt
at all they just give out
it just gave out and i don't know if i
would have felt
pain if it wasn't for landing on my arm
and
snapping my humerus in half and that
pain was
so severe that was so hard to watch it
was extraordinary pain and then when
bert takes it
and pulls it yeah why did he do that i
think he was like you're right but i
think he was
everyone's in shock should have he have
done that is that bad
doesn't have your arm like that yeah
it's not you do you're not supposed to
move it you're supposed to leave it
there yeah yeah yeah
and i have radial nerve damage and that
you know some people would argue that it
could be exacerbated by being moved
but some people would say that you know
it didn't
oh yeah right there yeah
yeah it hurts so much man i could only
imagine
it hurts so much uh i could only imagine
and then
you know that i i did something pretty
crazy uh so i went to a hospital
immediately right from the paramedics
came
and as soon as i as soon as i got to
that hospital
i looked around i don't know where i am
or anything i was like i'm not staying
here
so they why i just knew it was a shitty
hospital where were you
anyone saying i don't want to say but i
just knew i just knew instinctively
i was like really yeah and my memory is
so
you know when you have like intense
experiences your memory's so sharp from
it
like i remember so every detail of like
a month
like everything wow people i remember
everyone's name
you know so i got that emergency
remember that scott was in the bed next
to me
and then this uh nurse came in we did
x-rays
and there you know they put this
straight brace on my leg they're like
you know
tendon snapped and then they did a
horrible job
wrapping this arm in like a makeshift
kind of
splint brace you know and i was like and
then they're just
pumping me through they're like how much
pain are you and i'm like all of it what
are you talking about like
all the pain they're giving me drugs
and then they're like we need to have
surgery you know
so i i called my primary physician and i
was like who should operate on me
and he's like dude like the two
people i would send you to are out of
town right now i was like all right
so the emergency room doctor there's
like i'll set you up with this person
that can do surgery tomorrow and i was
like
no i'm not doing it here really and i
was like i'm leaving
and they're like you want to leave here
and i was like yep
they're like your your leg and your arm
are like
completely non-working i was like i
don't care
they're like are you sure i go yeah so
lindsay who works with me who was there
filming like getting his car i mean it
was hard
you got a guy named lindsay working for
you yeah yeah okay he'll hey he'll hear
this give it to him man
give it to him might want to change that
name
so yeah is he he him no no no he's he's
he's his pronoun he's very he him
yeah so that's his yeah yeah but he
doesn't put it in his signature
but he's a he's a great guy um so
lindsay helps me get in the car
sorry lindsay um and he uh
drives me home so i just go
i go home with a broken and half arm and
a leg
why didn't he take you to a better
hospital it didn't it didn't occur to
any of us
i didn't go take me to the hospital go
home so i went home
and bert and leanne had like helped set
up this area in our house
because our christina's like you know
beside herself like
so overwhelmed and they were really
really great
and i got on the couch and i slept on
the couch oh my god
and then the next morning bert had hired
i was like find me
one of the [ __ ] like wheelchair
drivers like that takes people around
he found a guy that for fifty dollars
picked us up
in a 30 year old van in a 50 year old
wheelchair
no yes and i was like who the [ __ ] did
you find he's like i don't know
so he you know i i do i i tell him this
i'm always like you know i'm a roll solo
like i'll be like i'll go by myself to
things i grabbed and i was like don't
you [ __ ] leave me in this family this
guy
don't leave me he's like okay oh my god
how old was guy driving the car
dude he was he reeked of cigarettes
his hair was so long that when he pushed
me like in the wheelchair
his hair would like be on my back oh my
god no
but i was in so much pain that i was
just like
just grinding my teeth he takes me
to an orthopedic surgeon like to this
office
and when i wheel into the office that
guy goes what the [ __ ] are you doing
here man
and i go what he goes you need to go to
the hospital like right now
and i go really he goes yeah man you
need to go to the hospital right now he
goes
i just saw like with the the x-rays from
last night he goes you
i mean just go right right now
immediately to the emergency room i was
like okay
he tells me you know this is gonna be
easy to fix
the tendon's like the real work but just
go
and it'll be it'll suck for a bit to
wait and everything but just go
so then i go to cedars in la
and then you know you have to wait and
we get into like the fast track and bert
you know is with me and then eventually
i get into a room
later that day and then two days later
i have surgery and then wow and then
from i stay there another few days
what'd they do with you for those two
days it was like
i mean they were pumping me full of
drugs they re-wrapped my arm which
so they had to take off the old wrap the
shitty wrap and i was like no
dude and then reset it and re-wrap it
oh man yeah that was that was so much
pain
and then then they operated and then um
a couple days later i go to a recovery
place like a rehab recovery place
for two weeks so that's why that's what
you know you're just
alone all the time yeah and it's it's
strange you know
and the two days of waiting was just
because they needed operating rooms
or just like so i that's the other thing
uh
i ended up getting like one of the best
trauma surgeons so i was like in the
trauma
ward and and this is like one of the
most sought after trauma surgeons so i'm
so lucky to get him and i tell him that
he's like tell me you know what happened
i tell him when i tell him i left that
hospital he goes
let me tell you something he goes that
is crazy but that's
one of the smartest things you've ever
done wow he was like that was really
really smart
of you to do imagine they butchered you
yeah he goes you know because it was
basically like
that these two operations are major
operations and like i have titanium
plates in here
you know and like so what does scar look
like
um it's just like
it's pretty gnarly i mean take your jar
and chocolate
yeah see the whole thing
now how long ago was this uh december
1st and the surgery was december 4th
bro that is a crazy scar so they went
right through your bicep
yeah and uh i love that one of the guys
pull that up
pull it up that's why i'm dead
and i still have like radial nerve
damage you know yeah not damage excuse
me
bruising so it's gonna take like they
said up to
16 18 months like month by month it gets
a little better
like i couldn't pull my wrist up like
this before
if i raised my hand it would just go
like that when did this when it become
better
like a month ago when i can grip things
but i can't use my extenders like my
hand doesn't open
all the way so when you do you have to
like do it
yeah or like i just have to place it but
when you place it can you grab that yes
can you do a chin up no definitely not
wow yeah cause i'm i'm i'm lifting
weights like
four or five days a week but it's all
light and it has to have to like i just
got permission to do
for for like months it was 15 pounds you
can only lift 15 pounds in this arm
and then he gave me permission to go up
so i did 20 and if i did rows
i can do like 25 30. but it's all
everything here atrophied you know like
doubt the whole
the whole rotator cuff area supe much
much weaker it's
it's weird like you're like that's not
heavy but then it feels heavy you know
oh wow
you know and same thing with like your
leg like i can do
seated squats holding weight here
but i can't like put you know weight on
my back right like but
but you know you do it like little by
little and you see the little changes
yeah i've been through a gang of
surgeries yeah yeah yeah i've had both
of my knees reconstructed oh so
yeah but like when this thing was in a
straight brace for six weeks
when that thing came off i mean you look
at my quad it was just like
weird right whoa and you put it next to
the other one and you're like oh my god
it's weird how quick it happens yeah it
happens real fast you know the whole
thing is that the experience becomes
like so intense
i i don't think like i can communicate
it to people
fully who who haven't either experienced
it or the only people who like totally
get it
like the intensity of the experience and
how it affects you are the pts
because they've seen it they work with
you know orthopedic injuries every day
like they know
that it affects you like physically
mentally and emotionally
nobody prepares you for that yeah so you
have a full year and a half
really before you left that right they
told me that you know they're like that
leg they go consider that a year
like a year before it's a what you were
used to before
the arm it's like they go they've seen
the nerve stuff because your your nerve
regenerates at one millimeter a day
so i don't have a dam i don't have like
a like a cut nerve but they're like one
millimeter a day is you know
it's really really small yeah so they're
like yeah we've seen people
recover in four months from their radial
nerve stuff and then we've seen people
that take like 18 months
so it goes just up in the air now did
you um
look into peptides or anything else has
any of that stuff helped you i mean i've
taken them
and i i feel better i feel good you know
and i'm
like you know i'm eating really clean
i'm i you look good i'm
saying when i as soon as i saw you like
you look thin yeah okay face looks
healthy yeah i feel i feel good and um
you know
the truth is i don't know what effect
the peptides have i take them
right and um i i religiously like i
follow that schedule
but to me it all feels like part of kind
of the ritual of rehab
so like it's like it's part it's dieting
it's exercise
peptide like all that is part of the
recovery and are you doing the rehab
through a physical therapist
yeah yeah i got a great one how many
days a week you're doing that we
were at three days a week then we went
down to two um
and then like now i don't really need i
don't need rehab anymore
on my leg i mean i need to work out and
get it stronger which i do but i don't
need her to
to rehab it dr karen juber she's awesome
um but she's been doing some of my
uh like shoulder arm stuff uh
working on this but the leg is pretty
much like just get it stronger now yeah
you just look
normal when you're walking around you
don't have a limp at all yeah which was
surprising i was like
it's only four minutes yeah yeah yeah
isn't that crazy yeah
yeah catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience